gleich drei
um diese produktion mit torte
nachzumachen
[Musik]
sally denkt wohl die könnte mich
herausfordert und dazu kann ich nur eins
sagen
[Musik]
warum nominiert du mich zu so einer
torte schön für die sachen die du willst
du geschickt hat endlich bin ich im
besitz von celle original vanille
extrakt ein original staley tortenring
und ein original zählt trombone mit rand
original plastikfolie und original sally
das ist tatsächlich ein original sally
spachtel die frau hat alles mehr haben
ich bin dankbar für die tollen sachen
wirklich herzlichen dank aber so die
anderes machen wollen im sommer bei 25
grad angenehmes klima perfekt um mit
butter krems und schokosoße zu hantieren
und für alle die jetzt nicht wissen was
los ist cellisten welt hat eine polo
tsunami torte gemacht der kate rennt
rennt 20 20 und hat stürmer kelly und
mich nominiert studie hat schon gemacht
würde sagen bei ihm ist es so
rausgekommen wie man es sich vorgestellt
hat mo fr
ich bin jetzt die nächste in der reihe
die styles machen trauen sollte hingegen
ganz gespannt so gucken uns mal den
tortenring berlin hat einen 20 cm
durchmesser genommen ich nehme meinen 18
cm durchmesser damit die torte
vielleicht ein bisschen höher wird und
das reicht ja völlig aus wie sie auch
einfach damit man sich so richtig
schlecht fühlt wenn man die challenge
nicht annimmt am ende die poliere so
zusammen und dann beim polo
ich bin gespannt ich halte mich auf
jeden fall an das konzept von sally
außer dass ich das toppen zu einem
rainbow kate macht wir beginnen mit
unserem schokoladen biscuit und dafür
brauchen wir dreier
eine prise salz 1 teelöffel vanille
extrakt original stanley über eine lex
diese frau hat einfach ihren eigenen von
den extra 75 gramm zucker
60 gramm mehl und 25 gramm kakao und
jetzt ins menü zubereiten verrühren die
eier mit dem salz vanille extrakt und
zucker in zehn bis 15 minuten sehr
cremig frühere das mehl mit dem kakao
und siebe es zu einer masse heben die
zutaten kurz vorsichtig unter fülle die
biscuit masse in den bug ring und bugs
sie für etwa 20 minuten nimmt den
biscuit aus dem ofen lasse ihn komplett
erkalten und löse den parkring mit einem
back vom messer was zur hölle ist ein
bug vor messer so es ist jetzt ein paar
stunden später ich habe mein outfit
gewechselt damit ihr euch auch optisch
daran gewöhnen könnt und euch das besser
vorstellen können dass ich zwischendurch
schon ein abendessen gekocht haben so
und kuchen ist abgekühlt das heißt wir
können heute noch weiter verarbeiten das
ist spät geworden bin ich ehrlich es ist
ein bisschen spät aber wir kriegen schon
ich hätte diesen pudding ich hätte
diesen kollegen machen wollte ich bin so
blöd und das brauchen wir für unsere
füllung strom halt bei stau eine creme
brauchen wir 500 gramm milch 90 gramm
zucker sallys wandel extrakt seine
stärke
weiche butter geholt und die anderen
drei eier und so wird die vanille creme
zubereitet verhöre die milch mit dem
zucker vanille extra weist der stärke
und der eigentlichen frei lasse den
pudding in einem topf barmittel hoher
hitze und ständigem rühren einmal
aufkochen zähne ihn vom herd herunter
fülle ihnen einen teller um und decke
die oberfläche direkt mit
frischhaltefolie ab damit sich keine
haut bildet lasse den pudding zimmer
beim abkühlen verhöre die weiche butter
in fünf bis sechs minuten weiß cremig
bereiche den abgekühlten vanillepudding
durch ein sieb und rühre ines
löffelweise unterstelle die vanillecreme
kurz zur seite so jetzt dürfen wir
endlich unsere torte befüllen und ich
hoffe dass alles gelingt das ist unser
perfekter bizkit boden smr der es
perfekt gebacken wie es mir das gelungen
und gold wir brauchen wir unsere
tortenplatte boden auf dem bogen und
jetzt frauen wir unsere formuliert der
regel gebastelt stunde hier alle
umgekommen
bei artec sekulic etail draufsteht mit
liebe gemacht ob es wahr ist verrate ich
nicht jetzt kommen zu einem kleinen
problem ich habe keine erdbeeren mehr
gefunden denn erdbeersaison ist sowas
von vorbei
dafür habe ich noch physalis und
heidelbeeren er sowieso langweilig ich
mache dir mal die erste schicht da haben
uns die creme drauf irgendwie finde ich
spritzbeutel super nervig und wenn ich
sie dann aber in der hand hat denke ich
mir so jammern ich bin becker dann
einmal
[Musik]
rand entlang und in den medien auch eine
ordentliche portion und jetzt nochmal
dem rand verkleiden mit neuen
heidelbeeren jetzt wird wieder rauf
gekippt war das könnte jetzt auch
einfach schon so ein kuchen sein
jetzt kommen wir wieder so können so
jetzt kommt der deckel drauf und an
drücken sagte gibt das habe ich immer im
ort zu backen und während ich backe habe
ich so spaß sein so unfair ok und jetzt
die letzte schicht drauf deshalb ist
hier gerade ist die gerade nicht so dass
monster muss jetzt in den kühlschrank
ich hoffe es passt da rein es wird
niemand rein passen so befinden sich die
zutaten die wir für die bowle cream
brauchen ich habe überlegt ob ich es
euch sage oder nehme ich habe mich bin
ehrlich ich musste die zuckerfee
kondensmilch von nestlé kaufen weil sie
diese russische aus der dose nicht
hatten
sally benutzt sagt peter krolle töre
weil ja ihre bono tsunami creme
schokoladig ist ich schokolade denn wir
machen ja einen rainbow bolobolo tsunami
sind jetzt zweimal sahne aufgeschrieben
ich weiß nicht genau was sie uns damit
sagen möchte aber wir nehmen erst mal
300 milliliter 375
und die stärke ich habe gezögert bekommt
des videos flüssiger 375 gramm und damit
ist meine torte nicht mehr laktosefrei
unsere sahne milch muss jetzt aufgekocht
kommt sie viel zucker bekommen wenn sie
mich rein
die marienglocke zehn stunden es ist
jetzt auch mal flüssig saure sahne und
300 gramm
jetzt ist komisch aus drei liter creme
es wird ich muss jetzt zehn jahre
abkühlen werden wir sehen uns dann
gleich so
ja was soll ich sagen es toll zu flüssig
wir brauchen regenbogenfarben dafür
teilen wir das jetzt mal auf rot orange
gelb grün blau lila 6 ich mache die
sechs regenbogenfarben und dazwischen
kommt dann immer eine dünne schicht weiß
das heißt wenn es verläuft gibt es coole
muster und nicht nur farben farben farbe
befahren von unten an mit leben die
tiere zu quälen aixtron diese bühne
ich bin ein pkw gefunden usa glaubt sie
ist wieder rausgeflogen habt ihr sie
gesehen diese farben sind viel zugkraft
und das wäre rot rot orange gelb grün
blau und lila es kommt jetzt glaube ich
alles noch mal in den kühlschrank damit
ein bisschen dickflüssiger wird und dann
geht es nun also die steine art geworden
ich würde sagen nicht lang schnacken
kopf im nacken als erstes kommt nicht
vor ich war nicht aufgeregt
[Musik]
dazwischen machen wir sind weiß sind
weiß rein
jetzt kommt darauf wieder ein schuss
weiß grün natürlich klar weiß game dann
kommt wieder ein schuss
jetzt kommt orange weiß und als letztes
in lila tal und so und ich mache noch
ein muster das so nach außen das predigt
geld ich war lange nicht scheitert mich
aber heute ist mal wieder so ein tag und
heute so unglaublich stolz auf mich
scheiße
sie muss die kamera und nicht nur das
sie so pretty awesome aussieht
jetzt guckt euch mal ich hoffe nur dass
es klappt eine weitere stunde kühlen
fürs machen ok ich ziehe jetzt ab jetzt
jetzt jetzt
[Musik]
die kritiker seien oder eine stunde hat
nicht ausgereicht ja das ziemlich
nützlich
das ist dem probieren bei fredy barth
viel zu dickflüssig da ist es überhaupt
nicht übergelaufen und bei mir also
seien überhaupt nicht dickflüssig aber
gott dass also die rainbow zunahme war
auf jeden fall keine schlechte idee
frage wie schmeckt die produktion am i
told you want sex welt hammergeil
erzählen was ihr wollt heidelbeeren in
der torte
[Musik]
die wie aus dem schotterboden hier
einfach mal in die soße reihen tunken
habt ihr so ein blauer bis selbst immer
vor ihr bringt diese torte zu dem
geburtstag mit es hoch und es läuft
ich habe euch das video gefallen und
jetzt richtig bock auf eine produktion a
wie rainbow tsunami torte bin extrem
traurig musste auf meinem tisch sind
extrem schön und wir sehen uns das nicht
immer wieder gefährlich für die
nominierung ich nominiere niemanden
ich tue das niemanden